si la nuit dont le mans
le duo de frères comptait prendre un
bain de foule cet été mais à cause de la
commune de 19
près de cinquante concerts prévus à
l'horaire ont été reportés à une date
indéterminée
mais si tout va bien on espère pour
l'autre on n'est ce pas pour l'automne
mais moi je fais plus partie de ceux qui
croient que ça va être plus en 2021
peut-être d'ici l'automne peut-être à
l'automne les petites salles mais en
fait personne ne sait
alors quand et comment reprendront les
spectacles de musique sur scène
possiblement pas avant 2021
en ce qui concerne les festivals et les
grands concerts comme ceux de marie mai
et elton john qui réunissent des
milliers de spectateurs collés les uns
sur les autres
personnellement je pensais pas qu'on
puisse voir de spectacles des bonnes
foules bébé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
candy carlton john chambres de la maison
en attendant de revenir à montréal et 20
qu à annuler ou reporter près de 600
événements
les billets seront remboursés ou valide
pour une autre date
son président invite à la patience on ne
referme en prospectant qu'a lieu la
distanciation
il faut trouver
[Musique]
le mur de la distanciation social de 2
mètres et un frein à la reprise des
concerts alors foudre at il vraiment
attendre l'arrivée de remède ou vaccin
le producteur martin leclerc qui a
reporté à 2021
près de cent soixante dix événements
aimerait avoir davantage d'informations
de la ministre de la culture
actuellement je me sens comme une
personne qui est sur une banquise sur un
iceberg et on est à la dérive
où est le ministère de la culture où son
ministre pour nous écouter
je sais que j'ai pas de réponse
actuellement mais regardez on est l
écoute et actuellement voici nous
ensemble mais c'est pas ça le message
surtout qu'on actuellement la ministre
de la culture a décliné notre demande
d'entrevue parce qu'elle est en attente
de l'avis de la santé publique pour
plusieurs
s'il y avait un retour des spectacles
dès cet été ça se ferait de manière
progressive et dans des espaces aux deux
tiers vides
il faudrait pas qu'il ya un tract pour
que les gens se rassemblent dans les
entractes il faudrait faire une addition
graduelle peut-être avec des biarrots
battait une partie de la salle
la partie les gens sont assis bac en
slip c'est ce qui vient
un éventuel retour en salles pourrait se
faire avec des mesures inusité devait
porter quelque chose on dirait plus vers
la vision qu'a vers le mas
sinon ça serait mieux une visière avec
le logo de la salle avec le logo du
spectacle il y en a des qui
réfléchissent à cette idée est loin de
faire l'unanimité
joy white qui représente une
cinquantaine de salles de musiques
alternatives prêche pour des concerts
hybride un show hybride c'est un show il
ya une partie du public qui est dans la
salle puis une partie du public qui est
chez eux en train de regarder un
livestream
et voici à quoi ressemblerait une salle
de spectacle qu'ils respecteraient la
distanciation social ici au cabaret lion
d'or il y aurait 60 places même si la
capacité en temps normal est de 250
places dire fait un plat maison avec une
distanciation de 2 mètres entre chacune
des tables
donc au niveau de la billetterie on est
prêts déjà à revendre les spectacles les
gens pourraient venir tout en tout à
fait sécuritaire mans les deux frères
brûle dans vie de remonter sur scène
sans indication claire sur la bière des
salles de spectacles ils ont décidé de
faire une tournée dans les ciné-parcs
rude sur scène avec un tout petit
système de son juste pour dire on va
être diffusé sur les écrans géants et
dans les voitures aussi comme on sait
l'impact dans les radios fm
alors si des musiciens centre l'appel de
la scène le public lui est il prêt à
faire la fête et à se rassembler autant
du corona virus
tél
à tous
ici louis fait depuis mai radio canada
montréal